les gestes de solidarité
se multiplient.
Notre correspondt t t t t t t t.
- Dimanche, devant l'ambassade
de Russie, un cri duururur
de ces résidents de Varsovie.
(slogans)
de l'importante diaspora
ukrainienne de Pologne.
(slogans), , , , , , , , , , , ,
macocococonflit l'a vite
rattrapée.
(sanglots)
elle se console en pensant
à la solida P P P P Polonais
à l'endroit de leurs voisins
ukrainiens.
aux militaires ukrainiens,
de nombreux Polonais font
nsnsnsnsns de sang comme ici
à Varsovie. Une campagne de dons
encore plus importante sera
dans un stade de la capitale
polonaise.
"Je n'irai pas me battre,
mais je peux les a",",",",",","e
qui a déjà attendu deux heures
rararararara encore patienter
avant de faire son don de sang.
humanitaire : vêtements,
nourritumememememements.
Depuis quelques jours,
les dons s'accumulent près
de la gestion de crise,
il faudra ppppppppppppui à plus
long terme, notamment auprès
des enfants.
Cette responsable d'un
organisme d'aide aux réfugiés
ononononononononononononononono,
entre autres pour emba
des psychologues qui parlent
l'ukrainien. Selon elle,
Elle s'attend
millions de réfugiés entrent en
Pologne si le iririririririre.
Tous ne peuvent pas compter
pour les héberger; des résidentc
aux réfugiés un toit sous lequel
dormir. Une chambre
disponible dans l'appartement
de la mère d'A
présentement à l'extérieur de
la ville. Pour cette Polonaise,e
naturel.
Elle ignore combien de temps
la cohabitation se
guerre. Agatha entend multiplier
les efforts et envis
Une implication qui lui permet
Une implicamememememememememet
aussi de ne pas être constamment
inondée de nouvelles sur
ce confl
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada, à Varsovi